Ron DeSantis is well positioned for a
run against Trump if he announces and if
he takes the campaign seriously and
he'll he has a shot there's no doubt but
if they emerge as the Front Runners
Trump and DeSantis and if they end up on
stage against each other and DeSantis
does this High Road stuff while Trump
brutally attacks the santus and he will
it doesn't look good for DeSantis I
don't actually believe that Republican
voters are going to be swayed by a guy
who takes the high road I think they
want to see who here brings the sort of
like you know what they what they
wrongly believe to be Alpha energy and
whatever else and uh I don't think the
Santa's taking the high road will work
and DeSantis does need to figure out how
do I attack Trump when do I attack Trump
or the chance that he has at this thing
is going to very quickly evaporate let
me know your thoughts what should
desantis's approach be